[Music]
and welcome to CBS this morning I'm
Anthony Mason with tonita copal Gayle
King is off so Michelle Miller of CBS
this morning Saturday is with us and as
you heard police in Gilroy California
are searching right now for a possible
second suspect in a deadly mass shooting
videos from the scene show chaos and
confusion after gunshots at the popular
Gilroy Garlic Festival last night police
shot and killed a gunman dressed in
camouflage three other people died and
at least 15 people were hurt among those
killed a six-year-old boy named Steven
Romero now we're at the scene of the
shooting in Gilroy and at a nearby
hospital treating victims we'll hear
from two white eyewitnesses as well but
we begin with Jamie yuccas near the
festival area Jamie we know there's one
gunman what are we here now about a
potential second suspect this is what we
know Toni witnesses reported seeing
another suspect but they don't know how
this person may have been involved or
whether he or she managed to disappear
in the crowd now it looks quiet now but
overnight heavily armed police FBI and
ATF agents search this entire area
police say there were no security
cameras when the gunman opened fire
shots rang out at the end of the Gilroy
Garlic Festival sending people
scrambling for safety witnesses say a
man appeared to the right of a concert
stage holding a semi-automatic rifle
singer of the band tin man heard someone
shout why are you doing this and the
gunmen reply because I'm really angry
it's like semi-automatic going off
really close to people screaming and
hiding and ducking they were getting
closer so I just started running I left
everything I ran I felt one of the
bullets go over my head and then we
actually seen a couple of bullets fly by
and that's why we just helped everybody
get out of the way get out of the scene
if flat I was gonna die this
seven-year-old boy
hid under a table since you were like
like 40 feet away from police say the
gunman avoided security and metal
detectors by entering through the creek
north of the park and using a tool to
cut through the fenced-in area officers
in that area and engaged the suspect in
less than a minute video taken after the
shooting appears to show a man
handcuffed on the ground surrounded by
officers nearby the wounded are being
treated by emergency responders the
panicked crowd evacuated immediately
some people were brought to local
schools others took shelter in
semi-trailer trucks waiting to be
reunited with their families it is such
a sad just horribly upsetting
circumstance to have seen this event in
this way this day is just one of the
most tragic and sad things that I've
ever had to see it's very tough this
neighborhood was on lockdown as well all
night as police searched by the creek
it's a largely residential area here so
people were told to stay inside their
homes this festival is one of the most
famous food festivals in the country
drawing more than a hundred thousand
people over a three-day weekend the
shooting happened as the festival was
winding down so if there was a silver
lining here there
may not have been as many people as
there would have been at its peak
Michelle yeah small thanks to that well
Jamie thank you